[Wes]So I'm very happy to be here at Mozilla with Brendan Eich,
the CTO of Mozilla, and the designer of JavaScript.
So u could tell us how that language came to be.
[Brendan] Sure. So I can say more about how I got ready
to make JavaScript. It was when I wrote Netscape. I didn't have much time to do that,
and I had to have the skills already.
And I've been just seated writing programming language implementations for my entire carreer.
When I got into Computer Science it was for Physics. First studying theory of formal languages
and automata theory. Regular languages, regular expressions.
This was the early 80ties and I loved the
cleverness of the theory and rather direct way of implementing
theories as algorithms.
So you can make a parser or a lexer , semi-automatically or automatically.
It was strange to me, and it was useful too.
I think every practicer in programs should take some time to invent a language
at some point. There's often a need you have
that no typical language is perfect for, or you have some leasure time
and you can use that. It's educational
and can often solve your problem
in a better way than any other language.
And so, I encourage that. I did that myself
and there is something that helped me to get ready to write JavaScript
because when I got into Netscape and the heat of the moment was there,
with Java looming. Questions about if we needed two languages:
a scripting language versus a big language as Java.
I had to go fast.
I had to have all sort... in my muscles I had to have some practice
already on the way.
[Wes] So in this class we will learn a lot of
the things he have just mentioned.
in various points. Regular Expressions,
Finite State Machines, adding a lexer that follows them automatically,
Context Free grammars, parsing, having a parser thet flow through automatically.
And I can only say that I really agree:
I have written a number of little languages
in my time to scratch various hitchies.
I think it's a very important tool to have under ones' belt.